- [Instructor] Divya received
the following problem.
A particle moves in a
straight line with velocity
v of t is equal to the square root
of three t minus one meters per second,
where t is time in seconds.
At t equals two,
the particle's distance
from the starting point
was eight meters in
the positive direction.
What is the particle's position
at t equals seven seconds?
Which expression should Divya
use to solve the problem?
So pause this video and have a go at it.
Alright now let's do this together.
So we wanna know the particle's position
at t is equal to seven.
So what we could do,
they tell us what our
position is at t equals two,
so what the position at
t equals seven would be your position
at t equals two plus
your change
in position
from t equals two
to t is equal to seven.
And there's another word for this.
You could also call this your displacement
from t equals two to t equals seven.
And we know how to think
about displacement.
Velocity is your rate of
change of displacement.
And so if you wanna figure
out your displacement,
your between two times,
you would integrate the velocity function.
So this is going to be the integral
from t equals two to t equals seven
of our velocity function, v of t, dt.
This would be our displacement
from time two to time seven.
So if they said what is
our change in position
from time two to time seven,
it would be just this expression.
But they want us,
they want us to figure out,
or they want Divya to figure out,
what is the particle's position
at t equals seven seconds.
So what you'd wanna do is your position
at t equals two,
and we know what our
position at t equals two is.
It was eight meters in
the positive direction,
so we could just call that
positive eight meters.
So it's going to be eight plus
your change in position,
which is going to be your displacement.
And let's see we can see this choice
right over there,
and that's what we would pick.
This first option,
v of seven, that just gives us our
velocity at time seven,
or at the exactly at seven seconds.
Or another way, our rate
of change of displacement
at seven seconds.
So that's not what we want.
This one right over here,
you have your position
at t equals two,
but then you have your change in position
from t equals zero to t equals seven.
So this doesn't seem, this isn't right.
And this is your position at time two
plus your v prime,
the derivative of velocity
is the acceleration,
plus your acceleration at time seven,
so that's definitely not gonna give you
your the particle's position.
So we like that second choice.